the las vegas strip has yet another new
attraction good afternoon thanks so much
for joining us at four i'm kirsten joyce
and i'm christian casadas world resorts
world is hosting their grand opening
tonight joe muller is live outside with
more on the big event joe
yeah that's right we have watched people
work for years to get this new resort uh
built right here in the las vegas strip
i'll give you a live look here this
evening we're just a few hours away from
an opening and take a look
this countdown has been popping up on
that giant monitor we are six hours 59
minutes and 40 something seconds
away from them opening the door now the
3000
room mega resort is one unique property
take a look at the giant monitor we just
showed you there
there is so much to cover from the food
to the casino now let's talk
technology something resorts world
wanted to make sure they were innovative
with
in the casino you can now gamble without
cash you simply download the resource
world mobile app and transfer money sit
down at a table
and scan in your play all right from
outside to inside you will see
dozens and dozens of monitors we talked
to doug green
from trust fall production group located
here in las vegas
they helped with a lot of the monitors
inside
i think they're sort of setting the
standard and now i think
it's going it's it's exciting for vegas
you know we all know
that uh you know vegas sort of sets the
bar for the us
so i think this property is now doing
that
definitely setting the bar all right
today is the big day and two hours of
ribbon cutting will take place out front
of
one of these several valet locations a
private party is set for tonight before
the grand opening now back out here live
we're taking another look
at the monitors two of the several
monitors that are here at the resort
six hours 58 minutes and 30 seconds they
will open to the public at 11 pm
this evening so if you wanted to go out
you can actually celebrate outside on
las vegas boulevard they're actually
gonna have a dj starting at nine o'clock
as well we'll send it back to you love
the countdown on the side there
all right we've been talking about the
amenities for quite some time there's so
much to offer what were you most
impressed by joe
yeah you know we did tour the inside it
was it's so cool there's so much to see
and
we've been in all the resorts around las
vegas but this really is unique when it
comes to the food there's
a street food area from with food from
around the world we talked to someone
from the philippines who was brought
here just to
open up shop inside so i'm actually
really excited just to get in there and
try
the variety of food options that they
have i think a lot of people will really
enjoy it
all right thanks very much joe
appreciate it we'll check back in with
you later